I thought of you fun today since this is
well you at home I'm probably watching
this later unless you're doing something
funny I don't know about today is gonna
be the last day the st. Louis Rams will
play in st. Louis ever in my lifetime
anyway so we I thought I would show a
world championship that had some games
played in st. Louis
okay and I was thinking wow it's really
strange that a world championship match
could be played in more than one city
and then I realized in 1990 pretty
recent Karpov and Kasparov played in two
cities so maybe it's not so strange they
played in New York and Leon and this
world championship match in 1886
considered the first official won by
most people some think you can go
further back was between synapse and
Zook retort which was played in New York
and then st. Louis and then New Orleans
and this match has two pretty reasonable
reasons why it's considered the first
world championship match one is if this
match was played earlier between
basically any two people you could
pretty easily argue that Morphy was
better than them that would be difficult
to argue now due to morphe not being
alive so with more themed or fees death
and the fact that there was a double
round-robin tournament held previously
at HT 83 with eight of the best players
in the world I'm sorry 14 of the best
players in the world double round-robin
26 games and Zook retort 1 with 22
points and I think sign has got
something like 18 and a half so those
were probably the two best players in
the world based on that criteria and it
took them a little while to get a match
going and they did now one confusing
thing about this picture of Zuko Jordan
Stein it's playing in New Orleans as
there's no chess clock and I did some
investigation and they they played with
the chess clock so I'm
guess whoever drew that picture they
played a strange time control like 30
moves in two hours then 15 moves per
hour now then it started very strange
way sign it's won the first game which
is what we're going to look at today
and then zuker chart won the next four
games and then the science was coming
back win draw and draw win draw he came
back he was leading by one point in New
Orleans and then the last five games
cited scored four and a half out of five
and the match ended because the match
was the first to win ten games and he
won ten games to five with five draws so
after Game five the Zook retort really
got crushed because super chair was up
four games to one after Game five and
then it was all downhill okay so I
wanted to look at this game because this
was the first game ever played in a
World Championship so pretty cool
science was black and the notes are
pretty funny because some of the notes
are by players from back then in some of
the notes are by more reasonable people
so ok so they played a Slav then World
Championship hasn't changed it's the
first one they play this now and after
e3 which has not played now but you you
would see Knight f3 and e3 or Knight c3
and e3 he played the move Bishop f5
which you probably wouldn't see here but
I think it's OK in positions where it
goes Knight f3 Knight f6 e3 Bishop f5 is
common
ok so mission if I was okay and this is
a very interesting game I think the
eighth game was the the one everybody
likes but this game is very interesting
because basically Stein it's played all
on the Kings side and zucrow played on
the Queen side and well it's sort of fun
game to watch maybe not to apply it
ok so white played Knight c3 although
usually when we see really early Bishop
f5 we the way to try to refute it is to
trade on d5 and play Queen b3 and we're
threatening the pawn on visa
and if the Queen tries to defend somehow
then the d5 point is hanging b6 is the
kind of move that I like to face what
I'm white and the recommendation of
course was Bishop c8 which actually I
agree with so that's the way to try to
punish Bishop f5 but white played 9 C 3
e 6 and we actually just get some
normal-looking position that you could
see in a World Championship today now in
this position if black could play Knight
f6 which would transpose through very
common position white likes to play
Knight h4 and try to get rid of this
bishop and sometimes black is like take
my bishop and sometimes black tries to
run away but but silence play 9 to g7 so
now 9 h4 is less good because it's
hanging so yeah it's not easy for whites
to play a move here because this is a
very nice Bishop I would say the black
is already just about equalized probably
grandmasters say we would play Bishop to
d3 and just trade the bishops but ok
white played a3 which is I mean not
terrible so Bishop d6 this move is given
an exclamation mark because it says it
entices white to play c5 so that's the
kind of annotations we had 130 years ago
okay Bishop d6 is fine
now again grandmasters today wouldn't
play c5 because it gives away the the
attack on the d5 pawn what black wants
to do over the next seven or eight moves
is either play C 5 or a 5 since Black
has played c6 it's more likely he'll
play e5 problem is if black ever plays
either a5 or c5 the d5 pot isn't
defended very much so often black will
take on c4 and then play e5 it's a
common idea in the Slav now white took
care all that you just played c5 which
again grandmasters today wouldn't do and
now there's no stopping black from
playing e5
and there's no pressure on the d5 pawn
that c4 pawn is gone and there's a lot
of positions in the slot where what
black plays 'if I've anyway white takes
on d5 and eventually black gets an
isolated pawn just to show you at home
let's pretend white plays Bishop e2 and
we'll just cheat a little bit okay
and after some of like a5 we could take
and take and you'll see that black has
an isolated pawn here
however when white plays c5 like you did
then we just play e5 for free and
there's no stopping v because blacks got
a lot of guys on u5 okay so
Zook retort is like okay you can play e5
and I'm going to push on the Queen side
and nowadays most grandmasters won't
play that way with white because black
gets an easy game in the center in the
Kings side okay but that's what these
guys did and he could take the pawn he
could play this very issue they give and
then put the knight on d4 but again
black has a very easy game and a lot of
positions like this where you see this
pawn structure which you see in a lot of
Slavs and Queens gambit declines the
bishop on c8 is having trouble getting
out and we don't know what to do but in
this variation the bishops already out
on a very nice diagonal so black doesn't
really have any problems okay so Stein
is played Bishop e2 allowing e4 now if
you look at one of my previous lectures
and actually I don't know what order
they're putting my lectures in I assume
by when I give them but could be wrong a
couple of weeks ago I won the last round
against Nick Carlo and even though that
was a King's Indian we had a similar
pawn structure
I played d6 + e5 he let me play e4
attacking his Knight and then I play d5
and I got this pawn structure like this
and my opponent was pushing on the Queen
side although he didn't play c5 ok so
sign is play Knight f6 gave one another
chance white didn't take it so sign is
play d4 and this is very interesting for
the spectator because blacks pushing on
the kingside and center and whites
pushing on the queenside
so I draw is less likely than a decisive
result and ok game is played on the
1800s there weren't too many drawers
they didn't defend perfectly now if any
Grandmaster today walks in the lecture
I'm sure they will they would take black
here black has more space in the center
and black has all of his pieces out and
they're all pretty active and white has
more space on the Queen side but I mean
White's King is going to be in trouble
and the silence actually showed that to
be true this was one of well I mean it's
the World Championship match as long as
you don't talk to Jacob Wilkins you'll
have a high opinion of long silence okay
so he played h5 which is what a
grandmaster today would do gaining space
on the King side black wants to gain
more space and if white ever plays h4 to
block this pawn then black has really
good use of the g4 Square and if white
castles there's going to be a lot of
attacking going on over here
too much attacking 92 instead of in this
position well after Knight h4 I would
guess I would play Bishop e6 you can but
I think you're in stirring your own
question I mean I don't want to play g4
although Nakano play g4 against me how
if you do so blacks threatening g5
winning the night I would be more apt to
play f4 here so that g5 is not possible
yeah I don't know your ideas are
dangerous at best okay so I just came
from my college class that I was
teaching tactics 101 and we were I was
teaching this
class dismissed
yeah all right with an eerie silence in
the room because the Queen's attacking
the knight so black just wins upon see
the this ain't no classroom there's a
world championship match that'll fall
for that yeah okay well I didn't
seriously consider nice for because I
was afraid of my night but you were gung
ho to play aggressively on the Kings
side so okay so night to d2 Zook retort
not recommended by Danny Machuca age 5
and he played h3 which the commentator
said is forced okay and they give some
other line b5 terrible Knight g4 Queen
h4 rar I mean I hate to agree with
annotations from 500 years ago but I
agree I don't like White's position okay
I don't know if I like like blacks
position either all right
so h3 night FA the Knights going over to
the Kings side if I was black probably
something like that a four-night g6 and
now the commentators recommending Knight
B 3 and actually I like the second line
they give g3 Queen b8 black wants to
sacrifice recommended by Diddy Machuca
okay attacking the blight King night f1
queen CA threatening the H pawn and
Knight g4 and I mean this is just
terrible for white King is going to be
here forever
rooks going to be here forever okay so
Zook retort played b5 night went to h4
steinitz played the way I recommended he
must have known well we can't let them
play night Jiggs g2 so okay play g3 I
don't know if I were to play g3 maybe
okay and now Steines went crazy which
but but correctly unlike certain other
people we will mention
well you know that you're a more modern
player however then you wouldn't let
your opponent stack all of his pieces so
much fun he's having so sign it's
instead of we're treating like a
Frenchman play Knight G to check fee and
cuddling is not and unlike most of the
moves played by players of the 1800s in
this position zoo crew are played the
computer recommended move that joke was
too complicated for this class King F 1
right now some of you may notice the
knight doesn't have a plethora of
squares that's because you don't have
imagination 9 to I 3 I even the computer
can find it ok so he played Knight takes
c3 check again the computer recommended
move F take c3 and Bishop take g3 so
this reminds me of like a demon cos
sacrifice
except black has sufficient compensation
for sure black has two pawns which is it
enough but h3 is weak my rook is coming
into the attack my Queens coming into
the attack and these pieces aren't the
best defenders in the world the claws
but they're not so this is what we call
a long-term sacrifice Black's go to
attack the next 10 15 20 moves and
White's going to try to get his pieces
next to his King ok good luck and again
it sort of looks like a simultaneous
because players of the 1800s weren't
quite as good as the best players in the
world now and sometimes even in World
Championship matches especially Steines
chigorin some of them whoo's were
suspicious some of the games that didn't
head moves ok so white play King G - I
agree it attacks the bishop and it
defends the pawn on h3 and it allows
white's pieces to come defend so Kim G -
seems good Danny would probably
sacrifice his Bishop on g3 is like they
may be yeah ok so Bishop went back to c7
that's a pretty good Bishop we need we
need to get a queen in here or a knight
in here
something going on get a rook over here
okay so white plague queen g1 probably a
move I would never consider because you
know that seems like you're helping
black plague rook g6 if I was white I
would be thinking my opponent wants to
play rook aged six to g6 so Queen g1 is
that the first move I consider because
that seems to make that better
okay but zukor had an idea then what
does the computer say queen f one's
losing 9f ones losing a dozen care cut
it says whites losing so Queen G one
rook h6 and his idea was King f1 and
maybe my king will run away in fact if Y
could play king c2 that's probably okay
then you won't get checkmate it'll be a
piece up okay rep g6 again the computer
moved by zoo court or what a fine player
because the bishop is controlling h2 we
can't put our queen there the queen is
attacked so the class will recommend f7
Queen f7 I knew what you meant
Queen f2 ok Queen to d7 was played
attacking the h3 pawn and white crashed
through on the Queen side okay rook g1
trying to trade rooks a good idea when
you're getting checkmated and Knight g4
not trading rooks so not only is black
threatening the night and has pressure
on the pawn on e3 Steinitz wants to play
rook f6 and attack the f2 square and get
more attack so you know if you just
walked in and some of you did you might
think why could Castle later but no
white already moved his King all the way
over here it's going to over here and
with all this extra space black has and
the three pawns and the active pieces
and the fact that these three four
pieces are just awful black should just
be winning here okay he took the knight
which is what I would do when I'm
getting checkmated I try to trade all
the
ESA's offs I don't get checkmated it's
my philosophy Bishop takes G for not
only recaptures but it keeps White's
King bottled up white can't run away so
black has two bishops attacking Black
has three passed pawns blacks rook is
really active on g6 and this work could
go to the B file and start putting
pressure here and I don't see what these
pieces are going to do sort of like a
morphe lecture finances playing like
morphe ok 92 excellent move try to get a
knight into the game Queenie 7 and again
black doesn't have to win right away to
show compensation for his piece he's
going to have compensation for the rest
of the game he's just slowly improving
his position he doesn't know if he wants
to move his Queen out if his Queens
going to go here when the White Queen
moves away if the rooks going to go to
f6 or if he's going to play h4 h 3h to
fab that's pretty good plan it's a nice
pass pawn
ok Knight f4 trading more pieces or
hoping to and he played rook h6 also
could have played rook f6 Bishop c3 g5
attacking the knight the knight retreats
and rook to f6 now that the G file in
the H file are blocked he's trying to
get his rook active somehow Queen and g2
and rook to f3 is a very nice move and
these are the kind of moves that are
easily overlooked i was playing an
israeli grandmaster about three years
ago here in st. louis named victor
Michalowski and he made a similar move
against me where he was white and he
moved his rook to d6 and i could also
take it with a minor piece but then when
he takes back he's crushing me and i was
like oh yeah he could just go there now
when my opponent plated against me a
similar move he didn't have any threats
his rook was just really strong on where
I was and I ended up winning the game
due to
incredible luck but here we're actually
going to play rook takes e3 and that's
really annoying if black plays rook
takes c3 the game is over the night on
e2 can't be defended and the night on e
2 is defending the bishop on c3 also
getting another pawn 4 passed pawns is a
lot so recap 3 you can't take it but you
can't leave it there so that's why I
wasn't playing this game I got nothing
to do in this game I'm just showing it
ok let's be pretty cool playing the
first official World Championship match
and having such a nice position with
black okay so Knight f1 I think is
forced the only move to defend the pawn
on e3 again if you take the rook pawn
takes there's a fork here and blacks
going to have too many pass pawns
too many bishops and too much material
so he played Knight f1 defending his e3
pawn so good move and he played the move
rook to b8 and again this game reminded
me a lot of morphe because in fact I
just gave a lecture on some of more fees
games some of you were here you at home
didn't see it kind of come to the chest
hope you want to see it and the rook is
really nice on the B file controlling
all of these squares threatening to go
there later making it hard for whites
King to escape over there and it's
clearly better than on a a where I can't
move up at all so the morphe style of
chess is not only to attack and improve
your position but to use all of your
pieces so rook be it as a real morphe
move because he's taking time out from
attacking on the king's side and taking
a rip that couldn't do anything and
making it really strong while at the
same time stopping white white from
putting his rook on the b file and again
if I show this to any modern Grandmaster
I mean they would all agree that white
is completely losing here black has more
space black has many more pawns even
though white as an extra P as his pieces
can't move his pieces are defending and
basically trapped and eventually the
white King is going to pay
okay King D 2 maybes finance was white
this game he liked to move his King f5
and it's hard to stop that avalanche of
pawns and white played a 5 a move that
doesn't really help very much there's
some other move suggested for example
Knight H to put some pressure on black
but in the end blacks pawns are just too
strong and this is a variation they give
and the White Queen is trapped I hate
when that happens
unless I'm black then I like it so the
bishop is controlling the diagonal the
Queen has nowhere to go and that was uh
I guess the main variation of white had
played best although that didn't work
out very well ok he played a 5 I I don't
really have an explanation for that move
waiting to lose F for breaking through
now he plays Rick h1 and blacks not in a
hurry so I can't do anything rook e1 F
takes e3 check
wow I really wouldn't want to take that
but I guess if I don't take it rook F
choose incredibly winning so and he
played rook F to another variation was
rook takes c3 King takes e3 Bishop f4
check if you take the bishop it's
checkmate but you don't have to take the
bishop you can play King f2 and out of
whoever imitated this game we rolled
King F 2x clam
although Dania Machuca can't wait to
have black here right there's no maybe
there's no immediate force to win but
this is just a terrible King and even
though white is up a rook and I like
being up a rook I would still take black
here ok but there's no reason to
sacrifice mature we don't have to Ricky
Rick f2 is good enough attacking the
Queen does the Queen have a safe Square
can you move the Queen and save it
let's see Queens g8 I'll never stop
teasing you never on that I'll never
stop TZ I know what you meant
yeah queen g1 then if I was black I'd
probably play Queen f3 and then I would
play Bishop f4 and then they would call
the police because that should be
illegal that's there's good and there's
not good that's not good okay so instead
he played Queen takes f2 sacrificing his
queen to stop the attack and then he
played Knight takes g4
so if black doesn't have any pieces you
want to tack so much good plant and
Bishop f4 check now this isn't just
sacrificing his queen I mean after well
I'm sure takes wins this Queen could get
trapped in here
Rick AJ check could be annoying so this
isn't so simple so I'll Bishop the ship
f4 check you can't take the bishop
because it's illegal its pinned so the
King has to move and now he took back
yeah it's unfortunate this bishop is
defending the rook okay and again
resigning wasn't the big thing back then
if we go back to this position and he
takes the knight right away then the
black Queen doesn't have the e3 square
to escape but because he threw this
check in now if the black Queen gets
attacked it has the very safe III square
and then d3 and will checkmate so
there's no way to trap the black Queen
you can't take the bishop because the
Knights pinned maybe there's some spike
checks Hey okay so he plays Bishop to d2
I'm pitting his knight but okay if this
was a World Championship match being
played today I would say in the last 70
years
white would resign but this was the
first world championship game ever so we
don't want to give up so Bishop d2 and
synapse played III looks pretty good
Bishop went to see one Queen goes to g2
not to attack the rook which is defended
but so you can play Queen e4 track and
once the black queen is in trap
there's no reason for white to keep
playing black has a winning material
advantage so for a world championship
game that was a pretty big crush what's
funny about it is for some of you were
here at the beginning the person who
lost this game Zook retort who looks
like he really got hammered he won the
next four games so chess is tough so
times he wins times you lose
he played king c3 no resigning King went
to d7 rook check check again and now
there's no more checks oh well this ship
takes this pawn playing for more checks
he checked him again solid and his hope
and this is we have a name for this that
the top players talk about this when
when your tricks don't work that's when
you're in trouble he's playing for a
trick if his opponent falls for the
trick he's still completely losing okay
the trick is if I take the rock that
Knight g3 check wins the Queen however
black is still completely winning there
so that's that tricks not so good okay
and sign it's played Bishop f4 cuz
there's no reason to lose your queen if
you'll have to although if you want it
to fall for the trick then okay
black is up two pawns and he's still
queening so King f3 would win pretty
easily
Rick f8 is the safe move then there's no
Rick f6 check okay but there's no reason
to lose your queen we don't have to play
Bishop f4 and since sign adds didn't
fall for his simple trick it was a world
championship after all now why he
decided to resign White's down a queen
for a rook black has two extra pawns and
black is probably good when more
material soon and if I was a betting man
I would guess if you put this on a chess
engine after about a minute it would
announce me that's my guess but I'm not
sure now what's interesting about this
match is for those of you who are late
again or for those of you who don't know
how to start from the beginning
some of this match was played in st.
Louis probably about a mile and a half
from here down actually I know where it
was but the buildings not there anymore
down Linda Linda turns an olive that it
turns in the World Championship and the
first two games were played in New York
then they played a few games in st.
Louis and they finished the mansion New
Orleans and science won the match and
became the first official world champion
and I mean I was surprised that before
this tournament before this match they
had played in the same tournament and
Zook record finished in Klehr first way
ahead of sine it's who came in second
and so these seem like the two players
who should play a match for the World
Championship some people claim
Zook retort was in ill health and this
wasn't his best chess that in the 1870s
and early 1880s he would have beaten
science but they didn't play that so and
in fact zouk retort died two years after
this match from a broken heart
no huh so some World Championship match
game is from the 1880s 1890's weren't
the best but I like this one because it
would have a good flow to it
white pushed all of his Queen side pawns
and got nothing and black pushed all his
kingside pawns and whites King went for
a walk in both directions and this is
the kind of game you would expect to see
if it was like McHale Tolliver's as an
amateur and a simultaneous not a World
Championship match because white got
beaten so badly but that happens
sometimes you get beaten badly and
losing one game isn't everything as
zuker to improved you won the next few
but I think he got tired and sick in the
middle end of the match and lost the
match and because of these matches the
Alekhine cap a blanket match this smash
the Karpov Kasparov match from 1985
nowadays matches don't take any time at
all because I think the organizers and
the public and the players are afraid
somebody is going to get sick if you're
playing I match the last two months and
you're going from city to city
I mean subway and
these matches happen that went to three
four five and actually six months for
the eighty-five match it gets sort of
silly so I think a good match would be
something like eighteen games then you
get to see who the better player is but
players nowadays and organizers they
like the twelve game format twelve games
to three weeks get in get out you're the
world champion in those days the last
for a month two months and whenever
somebody lost they went yeah I got sick
because you know that happens it's just
as tough right Bensimon
he can't even stay here for the whole
thing yes so he's sick and then he comes
back right if the lecture is more than
thirty minutes he's like no yeah exactly
we have to get in just the right amount
well I hope you enjoyed that game and
actually over the next few weeks what
I'm going to attempt to do for those of
you watching at home I want to show some
of these older games not just you know a
non beating topalov or last week it was
talk about beating it on that happens
and we're going to see some of these
older players you may not know a lot
about and we'll do a little Wikipedia
searching and find out about the
suspicious activities surrounding the
match this is chess history World
Championship match this was the first
game ever played an official World
Championship which was won by Steinitz
and the match was won by Stein it's
and we'll look at more games like this
in the future okay bye everyone
you